okay hi everyone we are back looking at
some more from language design and our
subject is meta data in trees
and this has to do with
how we should store
uh in the case of well we we saw this a
bit in the file system case
but now we're seeing it in more detail
in the abstract syntax tree case and the
XML case am I correct here
yep
um we don't have a representative here
so Brenton with his abstract syntactory
abstract syntax trees is not represented
here is that right I'm I'm here oh okay
great
is one of your abstract syntax trees
also here
are you here on your own without your
tree
um you can create a tree yeah the word
where it says container node call node
Leaf node those are examples of what
code parser gives
I thought there was also a point though
that this is not a totally faithful
representation because the code parser
also has stuff about parent trees or
something like that
well
well that's not like anything to do with
the data structures
all right let's take a look down this
list of our examples of trees with trees
with metadata
okay the first thing we have is XML so
these are all sections you can open with
examples
okay got these are hard to read
can I turn this into a tree
yeah that there's a matching subsection
in the next
that shows how it's converted into a
tree
okay
maybe there's an argument that XML
elements should format to look like XML
or something
that's a very good point why not
yeah why not
text element does that so
to look like
yeah yeah but if I take text elements
oh that's nice
yeah good point
okay so also relatedly if we're talking
about formatting real quick so let's say
sorry sorry to interrupt I was I was
muted and wondering why everybody was
ignoring me um I would argue that it's
much more important to see the full form
for an XML object than it is for
text element because people do a lot of
pattern matching against XML trees which
I don't think is necessarily the case of
text elements maybe I'm wrong but sorry
sorry you're saying you think it's
important to see the structure so people
know how to pattern match against it yes
okay that's actually a good point yeah
but you could have a mouse over that
shows that it's just unfreaking readable
otherwise
I kind of think that we expect to have
you know new transformation rules new
pattern matching compared to the old XML
tree which relied on sort of Legacy
pattern matching
you mean a special specialized tree
based pattern matching yeah three
transformations
you know so XPath to say where and xslt
to say what that kind of thing you know
I mean not exactly but well right but I
mean like we have regular expression
yes we're doing standard regex type
stuff I mean it is and we have Smiles
for dealing with chemicals and so on
these are nice compact notations and
there's no reason not to use them
I think the the thing with XML though is
that I mean every single time I've ever
used XML element I've always just done a
big cases at level Infinity around it
partly because there hasn't been any
better way to do it maybe exactly
Christopher no but you you're also I
think that that level of transformation
is accessible to us you know not a wide
group of people it's not super easy but
okay let's just do a survey here so
Okay so we've got XML elements we've got
I think this is what we asked for in the
last meeting it's just an inventory of
the types of of um trees with things
hanging off them that we've got so these
are the cases that we don't have nice
representations because these are the
cases where you have data and somehow
metadata and I'm using rules and lists
and associations
and we want kind of a more story who's
using I mean what you mean you mean when
you turn these into your trees yeah
okay
okay but I mean so what's happening here
is let's just survey What's Happening
Here
so
XML
is a payload
and then it's subtrees
is that right
yep
and
oh goodness sake text elements of the
other way round
no that's attributes
text element has only subtrees because
its leaves are no wait a minute you've
written this the wrong way I think XML
is that too basically it's just it's a
tag because the the
um
the uh the element I'm sorry did you
write this correctly yeah
oh it's sub trees until you get to the
leaf node where that subtrease is
replaced by a string
yeah some of these you don't always have
to have a list around it
a Singleton right this I guess the
subtree is just a string
but isn't actually not the same thing
XML is kind of the other way around but
it's just because it has a tag also yeah
exactly
right it's argument order is opposite
right I mean here's a question that we
might ask for some of these things
you know do we think we might change the
the XML structure to standardize it
yes I think we should well no no because
that would destroy all that pattern
matching that's the only way to use it
right now well I mean yeah not until
okay okay stop okay but all right so
we've got
the basic feature of these things is
they have a payload at that node that's
that's just a tag that's not the payload
that's that's
no I understand but this thing here I
know that that's the you know the
subjects is the meat of it like like
this is if you had like a link you know
tag would be okay the attribute would be
a href and then the actual body of it
would be sub trees
yes this is like HTML yep
and this should represent the Dom tree
yeah but I'm saying that the basic point
is there's a what this node corresponds
to there's an attributes and there's the
subtrees and here
there's
not really a I mean we could have
something and I'm allowed a little bit
confused by this
oh boy I think because you called
Everything text element there is no tag
no I understand but the point is that
yeah the tag here would be noun phrase
for that Outer Outer thing but in fact
we're putting the nature of the
grammatical unit
in in uh
in that Association
so I mean one of the things that is not
the case with Ian's trees at this time
is they don't routinely have a standard
for dealing with uh sort of you know
attributes of this type right we usually
call it annotations right we have to
change name from properties and
attributes to annotations
yes
um
but but okay but but we don't have
annotations in trees right now do we
correct we don't right but so in other
things this idea that we have an
annotation list
is is a thing in graphs in other places
right so so in a graph for example just
until we understand in a graph
I mean remind me how I annotate a graph
at the if I were to just type in a graph
so let's say I have a graph and I've got
you know one goes to two two goes to one
for example you can use wrappers around
them to just attach them so I can just
say annotation there yeah and then I say
something like um you know I don't know
color Arrow red or something
right yeah I know but sorry and I don't
see it unless I say
um unless I say Edge
what do I say Edge style Arrow
annotation what do I do
well I mean there should be an easier
way to call on annotations there
annotations in graph includes things
like style we've used style as an
annotation actually
it's just
um you know so there's
both vertices and edges can have
annotations and style in both cases or
standard what we call Standard
annotations that we saw so so you're
telling me if I say Style and what do I
do here unquote No style instead of
annotation
oh
the notation is when you want when you
want Total flexibility and naming what
the heck they are
okay all right so then then we've got
right now but if we look at the input
form right then presumably we see that
this is somehow
you know removed from there
right
and and do input form of out of three to
see how non-standard annotations get
stored
right it uses this annotation rules
on that edge
because it is canonically labeling the
edge
by virtue of of having those those right
which is very parallel right Edge style
it says that particular Edge has the
color red if if you read through the
rule of the the right hand side of the
edge Styles there
right sorry where am I going to put this
I'm going to put this and maybe SW notes
10.
okay all right so let's go back over
here
um
okay now we've got the notebook case
boy
The Notebook case has yet another thing
which is it has I mean we could have had
the same text elements and so on it has
this cell and cell group data and
notebook
yeah well and of course that goes
arbitrarily deep right right eventually
you'll have a box data and then a row
box and a superscript box and a template
box right I mean well I understand that
eventually it just goes into the
expression but the point is there's a
superstructure that we're thinking of
being the kind of the superstructure
tree which has Expressions hanging off
it which themselves are trees
I I don't I wouldn't think of it that
way at least not necessarily I mean just
like you know if I have a syntax tree
right I might have individual
Expressions that I go into but they're
all part of the same tree
right the the addend in plus two is
still part of my abstract syntax tree so
my I think it's also the case that there
are more than one tree for the same
object so for instance
[Music]
um
you know in compilation you often have
basic blocks as a node and that's just a
bunch of statements
which I'm saying and you you focus on
the branching too you know
and it's how much you want to aggregate
I think depends on the kind of
processing that you want to do
in the case of XML I think it's
it's easier in some ways at least
because it seems to me that everybody
wants to Dom tree the thing that I'm
confused by okay
you know for the last 35 years we've had
great success with Expressions that have
essentially a very simple tree structure
and you know we have a few standardized
things like options that hang off the
expression
but what's Happening Here is we've got
multiple annotated tree structures
some of which we're thinking of as being
I mean in other words we don't have a
standard way to annotate
it is what's being asked for here a
standard way to annotate our traditional
expression tree structure
or is this something different
so three objects are like nested
associations and lists but where you
have tagged nodes because you can have a
data
I actually wrote before I you know in
the night early 90s something I call
annotated Expressions they were like our
you know this before I was at the
company but in in C code where you have
basically our expression structure plus
annotations because I was writing
compilers
you know and that's what you do you walk
up and down those trees accumulating
information
right um so the basic question is how to
annotate a generic expression
I well okay well I suppose it depends on
what you mean by expression right so for
example the abstract syntax tree and the
notebook right they need to be
representations of text or right of
things that users typed in that may or
may not actually correspond to a you
know a wolf from language expression
right people can type in things with
syntax errors in them and the abstract
syntax tree and the notebooks still need
to be able to represent those things
whether or not you know even though
shift enter will you know not do
anything particularly useful or at least
of limited utility when you do that okay
but also here how we map it to a tree
depends on what how we want to process
it so I think it's important to write a
few prototypes that show that you know
there's going to be trade-offs
um
because you want to be able to access
and add to those annotations as you
process it
all right but so
you know for example with the compiler
recently We've Ended up with these two
different constructs typed and what are
we calling it type or what is the thing
that I pinned I think okay type hint
okay so I've heard of this thing yeah
okay so guess what this must be recent
that's recent yeah so typed is a totally
inert thing that you can manipulate you
can have giant typed Expressions you can
do transmissions on them Etc type hint
is something that can appear in compiled
code but which were that compiled code
to be run top level the type hint would
just just evaporate away
but were the compiled codes to be
actually run in the compiler the type
hint would cause the compiler to do
something special
and so that's in in terms of The
annotation that that's two different
kinds of annotations one of which is an
evaporating annotation the other of
which is a static annotation that in
order to do an operation I mean I I
don't know whether we have any mechanism
to like clean the types out of things in
other words you know I mean you know we
could imagine a thing that says you know
ignoring type
types Expo
I think this difference though comes
from the fact that excuse me there are
two there are two different environments
which code is run in the context of the
compiler so all the type hint is is just
saying that there's you know it's
handled differently and the two
environments as opposed to typed that
kind of isn't
but yes but here everything is just
evaluated
but well okay so so does type in only
can that can only be used in the held
code because if you otherwise just goes
away right I mean so it's just an input
it's it's used as a typical piece of
input if you say function compile blah
blah blah it's used there right and
typed is used I'm not sure I agree with
Christopher's description right because
typed you know it appears in the
Declaration of capital function
but you know if you were to evaluate
that function outside of the compiler it
would just be ignored right it's only
right well ideally right we've we've had
bugs with things that try to manipulate
function and forget and aren't aware of
this but you know if function evaluates
it just throws that away if during as
part of normal evaluation
right so this was the distinction that
we ended up making because so basically
right now as in you know before like a
week ago when taipint was sort of you
know implemented or whatever the way it
worked was that typed did two things it
one was the thing in the Declarations
but it also was the thing that would
appear in in code that would tell you
that oh by the way this thing that's a
list that's you know a packed array
versus uh whatever else
um but but now the idea is that those
are those are done separately so now
typed is only going to be used in
declarations
um all right so let's keep going here I
just want to go down the other cases
here go down the tree yes indeed so this
is Brenton's
uh
abstract syntax tree correct yeah
well this is a concrete
that yeah well it's the abstract syntax
tree of the of that particular string
well no it's the concrete syntax tree of
that string not the abstract yeah people
are yeah it's a it's okay people are
really bad about saying sticking what's
the difference I'm sorry what's the
difference well concrete is you know a
lossless representation of you know you
could consider you know white space and
comments and the plus sign that you
entered and everything but whereas the
abstract syntax tree is just the
semantics supposedly well you know yeah
I mean as as yeah I mean for us it's
very convenient I can just say think of
the full form and you know that is that
is what the abstract syntax is uh you
wouldn't be able to say that in many
other languages but
um but yeah that's that's us
well it's because we're a symbolic
language fancy yeah yeah
okay code element this is Chris
Cooley's uh work
and
looks rather clean
and this is very similar to The Source
you've got a source range
I don't quite understand why you have a
why do you have those two
well it's line column
yeah mine's character position
okay okay which if you said if you gave
an option to my concrete parse it could
also give the character position but
yeah it could give the same output as
that
okay I I'm I just a small design point I
mean I think we really need something
where if we are going to represent in
terms of line and column we need a way I
mean like for example we we should have
a um you know line column
uh way of accessing text so in other
words if I wanted to extract
you know if I wanted to get that one
five one six right
um this is just string manipulation
stuff uh we don't have a good
representation for aha that's a good
point you mean like if you did string a
way of saying in string cases yeah
exactly oh that'd be I mean that'd be
extremely nice and I would use it and
that would be yeah yeah I I would
advocate for that
right so I mean what we need is go ahead
imagine Saturn I was just thinking right
now I mean that would be some you know
string split on you know on line breaks
and then you do park by the row and then
you do string take by or string part by
the column right
we could almost call it card
never mind we're not going to call it
card anything to do with cards I'm
joking right I mean sorry that was
almost like the joke but that's okay I
guess oh gosh everybody's too young for
this joke oh
the I've seen those
the anyway no but I mean what what this
wants to be
because I mean we could also it would
also be useful to have a symbolic
representation
from get for example when it gives
syntax errors if it knows
I mean we should have a way of
representing a line number and a file
and a line and column
line column plus a span of those
first then you get into the question of
do you want the a linear span or a
rectangular span
well you mean I mean I mean I guess in
this context you really want the linear
span right but of course emacs gives you
both Concepts
right you you have the linear
uh right given a line number two
positions in the file you can talk about
either that linear stretch of characters
or the rectangle defined by those two
points but it's not even a rectangle
those either that's ragged yeah well
it's potential it's potentially ragged
yes but it's it's incredibly useful when
you're you know when you have
well-formatted code and you're you're
trying to
let's take this to ild maybe for
discussion this line column stream
manipulation thing minor Point let's go
back to looking at this
um
so
what Chris has here is code element
token
and then you've got
the actual word the actual text
which boy we have so many different ways
to do this I mean there we've got the
actual text again in a cell
right
and then
as a leaf it's a leaf but look here
there's different heads in the notebook
right
and remember XML didn't have that they
had to have to store the varieties of
heads as a text which is the tag right
and same thing for that uh [ __ ] thing
he says code element and then it has to
or code element token and then it has to
have a tag
exactly main or whatever right right so
so I mean the modalities are either we
have uh multiple heads
EG sell versus Cell group data
or
we have
um tags as first element
EG now what does text element do again
oh for goodness sake text element does
neither of those
yes thank you for saying tags as first
element I vote for that yes
or in the case of uh no tagging I.E IE
single
uh I all nodes the same
which is the case EG text text element
right
and I believe that case is also the case
for
you know a generic expression
I have to say that I find text element
weird I mean maybe it's just because I
haven't thought about this very
deeply but it seems to me strange right
all of these have Singleton associations
so why isn't the right hand side a tag
of you know the basic structure and
maybe you need additional information
that could go in an association or list
of rules but it seems to me like the
grammatical unit is something you you
basically have to have maybe I'm wrong
that's the problem that's why we had to
do it this way you don't have to have a
grammatical unit
because you can have pure text that is
identified with text elements but where
you don't know
I'm trying to remember how this worked
um where you don't know whether it's an
adjective or not
right and in addition there's many other
things you could tag here and maybe text
structure even shows some of that other
tagging the association is actually
optional in text element
and so what does a single 10 text
element mean
it means it's a thing where it's an
unknown if I say text element of Foo
oh I get nothing
that's odd oh maybe I if I do this what
happens
if it's more bizarre
uh so apparently you do need to have a
grammatical unit if you use the two
argument form a copy a valid text
element from somewhere
just pick a text element okay what's the
difference in this one here I go to
valid text element there okay now new
text element of list of that twice
right
oh that's there's no grammatical unit
associated with that it's just like a
forest of text
it's a forest of trees which in fact
might that that's actually a sentence
marker that's very bizarre I'm not sure
the test element's the right thing okay
but but so
okay So Okay so we've got first of all
we've got
this thing here is you know basically
type tagging
that's the first thing and then we've
got uh attributes
is another aspect of these things and
we've got the payload everybody has a
payload and the payloads work more or
less the same in all cases although the
payloads might be named payloads like an
association of subtrees or a list of
subtrees
uh do you agree so far with the type
tagging with those three things that you
have listed right there are those
exclusive well no I'm just I'm just this
is Natural History okay okay I'm just
I'm just saying what we have right now
um okay so with attributes
what do we have how do we do attributes
what are the ways we do attributes
so rules
and predated Association right
well so but mostly
I mean the thing is we've got this
complete zoo of what the order of the
tag versus the attributes versus
whatever else
see I'm I'm just wondering
okay let's let's discuss what we do in
trees
now
entry the only thing we're doing
differently here is we don't have type
tagging
as such
well what we have in a tree is we have
payload followed by subtrees right
but we don't have any standardization of
payload
exactly see if if we standardized
payload into tag and attributes
let's just imagine just for the sake of
argument that we had a a rapper called
payload okay no I'm not saying if
necessarily a good name but but and that
it's
it was standardized into tag and
attributes
would we then have a convenient way to
put all of these different tree types
into all these different tree-like
things into a generic tree structure
almost
um
cell
has
a third thing which is a sequence of
styles
okay so that's a special case of
attributes
well what I was going to do Styles I was
assuming that was type tagging that like
I would think of cell Styles as type
tagging myself
though
is the point that I'm making
oh I see yeah yeah right you can have
multiple cells even or Styles even no no
the problem is that what what what
um or none is pointing out is that you
both have cell
and you have title
you see they're both taggy type things
holy sure but one that's more right it's
a particular instant right I mean cell
has a very definite meaning of you know
what it's
you know remit is and then you can have
different types of of cells
right I know that my point is if we were
going to standardize on payload here oh
I see
we wouldn't have a place to put the cell
name
if anything there's actually a another
modality in that list of of you know
different heads
even you know sell the multiple heads
that's this case here well but is that
well if that's not its own item I mean
no I I know but the thing yeah yeah
we're trying to take all these different
tree types and we're trying to figure
out how do we map them into Ian's trees
okay and the whole point is Ian's trees
have this form payload subtrees and so
what I'm arguing is the way we do it is
we standardize the structure of the
payload piece
Ian does that make sense to you does
that make sense to other people here
yeah I I have two proposals one is to
somehow try to use annotations and the
other is basically this come up with
symbolic representations for the payload
okay what's The annotation idea
can you scroll down in the agenda
notebook well maybe we should actually
look at how things are represented as
trees
in my world I'm thinking of attributes
or annotations in fact I wanted to call
them attributes but we use attributes
for something not so useful
you know since long time
yeah right anyway
okay one question sorry so payload would
be something that you can have in the
first argument not something that you
need to have
that is correct it will be the
standardized way of translating an XML
tree into an Ian tree so to speak yes
but we are not forced to have a payload
object in every tree
that is correct you can just have it's
just like you're not forced to have in
an expression you're not forced to use
list or something you're not forced to
Expressions can have all kinds of wacky
forms eons trees can have XML and C
mixed it can be a very hybrid tree
we graphed C code onto XML yeah in
principle
right I mean and which okay
comes in so you can specify like a
well-formed tree
for a certain type
right okay so there's a different issue
here which is the the schemas
and um
and woofed well-formed trees
okay let's look at yours so what I I'm
still trying to understand exactly what
payload is right because so I have cell
of you know my title comma title and you
know font size goes to 72.
and so where does my title go in the
tree
and well we're not sure what size goes
to 72. contest goes to 72 is part of the
attributes
type things is that right yeah yes
that's the idea and the idea is that the
schema will basically say you know for
example the schema might say payload of
you know tag one or tag two
and then this would be like options
pattern or something
maybe maybe not that but you know
something like that but that's the
schema
I'm not sure that's right but but but
let's look at Ian's stuff here okay so
I'm sorry I had to explain this how how
would it work open that section above
prose
okay
it's not so this is some it it's kind of
following how annotation rules Works in
graph wait a minute how does this case
work how does this case work with the
pure subtrees here
how do you how is this not ambiguous
or is it not ambiguous already tree has
a tree has options as a as a third of an
optional first argument
okay and sub trees is always a list or
an association
or the symbol none yeah
and this isn't ambiguous
correct
okay
so this is adding in
all the sort of data
so XML
okay I'm not sure how it's not that
ambiguous but we can postpone that
conversation
okay
I don't understand this one so trees uh
text sorry at the end there's a thing
where the sub trees is where instead you
have a text common none
yes yes the leaves the leaves there
would be tree of a string comma none
okay with some annotation rules
maybe yeah right well yes definitely
because they're going to say what the
grammatical unit type is okay so that's
proposal number one
and
yeah
is that there's like a distinguished
this is all kind of data right but the
idea is to have a preferred thing that's
the actual data of the tree and the rest
is split off and considered metadata
somehow
yeah but I mean look for example in
Notebook import
okay it's really important that we be
able to say get me all the title cells
and that's pretty obscure here I mean
that that pattern is going to be a messy
pattern
we could provide some helper functions
do we have annotation matching type
stuff
for graphs
I was thinking that you know here the
value of these proposals gonna strongly
depend on how you use it to process
like how easy is it to access
the values of some of those annotations
you know and if we just have to use the
pattern language it's kind of clumsy
I mean it's possible but it's a little
clumsy yeah yeah I mean we need utility
functions to do that
we'd need something like the options
pattern mechanism to deal with this
yeah something like annotations pattern
or something
yeah
which is not impossible I mean the
options pattern stuff I would say is
modestly successful
right because we've got to be able to
extract like for example I want to find
all elements of a tree that are title
cells
right how do I do that
guys
yeah I think that that needs to be easy
it's really not clear to me how you
would do it with this form there's
annotation value but the problem with
annotation value is it's a function that
takes the object
as one of its arguments
right okay
but I mean isn't it just right you look
for uh
you know you just stick a key value
pattern in the third argument with you
know cell style goes to title
well it's more complicated than that
because it's got multiple Styles here
doesn't matter that's what key value
pattern does
oh but this is uh but this is style goes
to isn't even an association
doesn't matter key value pattern accepts
lists of rules okay
um
right so instead of stat instead of
instead of styles goes to title it'll be
Styles goes to blank slash semi you know
member Q yeah that's pretty ugly yeah
I mean
okay
I'm actually forgotten our key value
button works
okay
I'd forgotten how this work this is
really nice and let me introduce this
oh my gosh
we introduced it that long ago yep
wow
and we did the first round of pattern
matching for Association and 10-2 and
this was sort of the second round
was that the last round I thought we
were I thought we did more pattern
matching and associations more recently
was wasn't pattern matching an
association with trailing a suit for a
while
[Music]
um
I think it was a trailing issue until a
key value pattern was introduced at
least as far as I was aware yeah okay
yeah I mean there there are I mean there
are some issues but I don't think
they're they're
um
there there's an there's been sort of
any sort of me gosh time goes so quickly
the association was 2014. my gosh I
thought it was much newer than that well
good I'm glad it's that old okay
all right let's look at the symbolic
data idea this is your other idea
yeah so the symbolic representations
that we already have like notebook and
text element and XML element they
somehow represent the entire tree
including its sub trees
so the idea here is to make
parallel versions of those but that
represent just the payload
oh boy and then they can be all
specialized for their different use
cases
foreign
matching
yeah one benefit of this is that you
could just do tree cases on this
like there's no metadata it's just data
I understand this is similar to the
payload idea this is a specialized
payload idea
so we could in general have a we could
have an an arbitrary payload and then we
could have specialized cases a
particular rapper node wrappers
mm-hmm
Okay so
gosh you know and go ahead and so you're
saying that data
oh I see that's both the pro and the con
but what what are what what why are you
claiming the data and metadata are
combined
you're claiming that because
is is data not metadata
metadata
what's that
this makes no attempt to distinguish
between data and metadata except one
object representing all of it
like a cell node represents the Styles
and the options
yeah I suppose it depends on your point
of view whether style is data or
metadata
but right because I think of the first
argument as the data and style as the
metadata I mean it's very important
first argument of cell is a sub tree
in this like if you look up to how
notebook gets converted into a tree
like up in the in the agenda notebook
the fact that we don't agree on what
data metadata is means that it's a good
thing to have them together
yes I agree so you see cells that don't
have a cell group data always just have
a leaf that's the boxes in that cell
you can see that with a tooltip
okay
all right let's come back down here
I mean
introducing a modest number of new
symbols to represent these nodes doesn't
seem crazy to me
if they can be given you know nice
functionality
I think there needs to be a generic one
this idea here
seems pretty awkward in terms of our
standard pattern matching modalities
I agree and it would also need some kind
of supplied type mechanism
to be able to have functions operate on
the tree and pull in so why why wouldn't
um right so why wouldn't your other idea
still require you still to write
something like
you know
trucel nodes of x blank blank comma
options pattern slash semi or x blank
blank string comma options pattern slash
semi member Q
title uh
of the list
my view is it's not they're both kind of
like equivalent in terms of pattern
matching but the problem is how do you
even access the data if it's all in the
data we already have a way to access the
data
I see
what do you mean by that at the end
so like functions like tree data return
the data functions like tree map apply a
function to the data
what what would be the equivalent if you
wanted to map a function over a tree and
have the function apply to these
annotation rules
yeah sure yes it's a mess
no I agree that's a good argument for
the fact that there is a tree map that
can pick up the whole payload at that
node and do something with it seems like
a relevant argument
another Advantage is that we could have
special type setting for each of these
things and it would work even outside
the tree framework
yes like the XML node could type set as
a piece of XML exactly
okay
you didn't
okay I mean there's clearly some cleanup
that's going to be needed like this that
has way too many pieces here and that
needs to be thought through and so on
you didn't include the Chris's
um
what does what does this have it has
code elements and code element token and
that's it right
um
okay so I mean there will be other node
names yeah there could be like a code
node that has a type and the
source
um
okay
so where are we going from this and I
we're running out of time here okay
to me it seems like proposal number two
together with a generic payload wrapper
seems like the more promising Direction
however I strongly think we need to we
need to figure out they're going to be
using utility functions for that
matching and there also is going to be
sort of the xslt style you know tree
sampling both
doable
with a pure
sort of uh
kind of tree
what am I saying
um
should work for arbitrary trees as well
as specialized trees
yes
um
okay all right so then
right I mean we we need to understand I
don't really understand do you
understand how xslt type or XPath and so
on stuff
now you have the equivalent of X part
nice we have a design for XPath
um and how would that relate to any of
these I mean the the one thing that's
good about this about the second thing
is that you know the path just goes and
drills into the sub trees
and there's one thing that is is the
actual payload at that node
and you're not trying to pick up two
different things with an annotation as
well as a whatever
right
also kind of the idea of XPath is
combining
information about the position with
basically pattern matching
it's like a hybrid pattern position spec
okay well again that's probably not we
may have to have some utility thing to
pick out the you know
the options part of this
but that's that's what I think
regardless of the representation
that's what we would want even for the
first case to you know just be able to
pick out the values sure no there
look I suspect okay let's combine okay
my guess is that the generic payload
case can be done with something like the
annotations mechanism
what is the is there a rapper
before you get to annotation rules is
there something I'm now forgetting is
there a pure annotation yes there is
that's what we were showing before
in this case here
this annotation wrapper
almost becomes an annotated node or
something
as the generic for the payload
that make any sense to anybody
for the key value type
annotations yeah yeah but that what what
that would be is you could have
specifically a cell node or something
or you could just have a generic
annotated node
I don't know if that's right I don't
know if that's right
um
okay
well uh
what's this so
um
okay what else should we make sure to
cover right now
so you think this direction of of having
these node that's what I think is the
best there's no good convention for the
name
okay could be anybody else got a comment
about that
I mean we're calling it vertices in a
graph but I think that means you know
node is free for this concept
any thoughts anybody
Christopher etai anybody
your thoughts I I like note
yeah I think it's fine
but what about this channel Direct I
think this general direction is the
right one because I like the idea of
independent formatting for node star
node objects
I have a feeling we might end up
changing
well for XML the question of the default
import for XML
you know might get changed text element
might text structure might change in
terms of its default return object
notebooks I mean
or alternatively many of these things
could just if you say three of them
that's when they turn into this kind of
form
yeah
um there I I would argue there always
needs to be a way of seeing the flat the
existing way of you know you see the the
notebooks and the things above uh to be
able to construct to do pattern matching
on you know for you to be able to write
that and see what's going on as a you
know flat text almost flat text in a way
uh there's still there should always be
a way of getting what currently is the
current behavior well in which cases in
the case of notebooks maybe I mean it's
pretty inconvenient
honestly I mean
but you we have double so with double
and triple clicking
for you know here in the front end like
it's it you know it's extremely
convenient to be able to dig down and
and see like what the you know what what
tree structures are to be able to write
up patterns you know to do patterns
listen I I argue this is basically
unreadable
and it probably helps that we've got I
mean look at that thing it's unreadable
but it's what you need to see if you
were writing patterns to do pattern
matching I understand but but I'd like
to argue that this if this is better
formatted
right that maybe it can it can still you
know all the characters can be there but
there can at least be some line breaks
or something in there
uncontroversial yes yeah
what would happen just so I understand
Brenton how do I format this with your
line breaker
oh it would need to be I think it has to
be an input just convert it to an input
cell first
but it I don't think it does output
how do I do all of this a cell
conversion right
okay now what yeah and then um right
click somewhere in the cell I can't
remember if we added a menu like in
notebooks if we added that see it's in
the package editor but I don't know if
it's in regular notebooks we are losing
yeah my friend come on you can do it in
in the package editor I've seen the
button what happened
or so
okay so you're telling me if I go here
yeah and then just format cell that's in
the toolbar there
you need to have to sell selected oh
it's still not it's still output
um there's still an output label I don't
know if it's
not
that output label I think is relevant oh
yeah yeah fine actually that's a bug
that that got moved over there
okay I'm not I'm not this is not making
it for me well no yeah that's the format
that's what it looks like yep
might be a little bit confused because
the whole thing is there's this XML
object of document around all of it
well I would not say this was a banner
moment
for this formatter
out of curiosity could you try taking it
out of that outer wrapper
yeah
how do I do that so I just saw maybe
maybe to get rid of the airiness but
foreign
ER has a lot of room for improvement
oops
okay now what so now let's de-erify it
make it lesser Maybe
okay okay that's very hard to tell yeah
what you have is not syntax Q
right see the red comma it starts with a
curly brace and it ends of the square
brackets which is suspicious which you
will notice the formatter is not
complaining about
maybe just delete from the comma upwards
and just get rid of the Declaration as
well
you can just triple click on one of the
XML elements that looks like it's the
outermost one and then just copy that
otherwise I think we're just going to be
are you sure that's an expression
yeah
there's something weird about this this
is really looking terrible
I'm sorry yeah it's just
is this can you can you try this though
instead of copying the selling you just
do this go back to the The Notebook
okay triple click on one of the XML
elements copy that
then paste into a new cell in here okay
now it's not an input cell
it's actually the right kind of cells
now what do I do well click it and press
format Excel don't you
okay
now reduce the airiness
I mean it's it's just the same I mean
yeah okay fine it didn't work I mean oh
this looks like it worked better than
what we saw before but that might be a
bit that's basically this this is a good
example Brenton of a bad example of of
how the airiness is working because this
should be able to aggregate these things
onto the same line without crunching
everything up
well I mean and and you know well I mean
personally I would like for a mode where
the commas was on the same line rather
than but it's online
could be turned what should happen is
these should be on their own line but
these separate XML elements should be on
different lines I mean look it's it's
not that we are bereft of things that we
know need improvements were bereft of
the the time and priority to funnel into
this at the moment right compared to
other stuff in Britain's queue yeah
right I just want to make one comment
about something that I noticed okay if I
type X close bracket
no that's not the case
what is the freaking case there's some
case
where you don't get
oh yeah if I add them wait a minute so
but I think that you know question is
where you want to get and what I hope
that we can get to is that
you know two use cases are super common
one is I want to extract some
information out of this tree it should
be easy to extract
two I want to transform this tree in
some way maybe pick out the subtree uh
maybe use some other elements to
construct a new tree
that should also be possible that that's
transform is wide open
you know meaning that there are many
I don't know what the typical I mean so
so typically you ingest a tree
I mean you know it's what we do with
Expressions all the time we ingest an
expression it matches some pattern we
use the pattern variables to pick out
pieces of the expression that were
matched yeah and we return a transformed
version
yeah and that's what that works really
well right the question is what the tree
analog of that is
right exactly so the reason what we have
now is basically the standard functions
for working with positions and levels so
you can do you know tree position tree
extract
tree replace part tree insert but what
we don't have yet in the trees project
is like pattern matching and
transformation right pad matching based
on comfort as opposed to a replace part
which is based on part location
we don't have content-based pattern
transformations
right we only have position based
transformations
so it's a little bit like adding a while
loop you know we have the for Loop and
we want to add the Y Loop
you know data dependent absolutely
you know as opposed to fixed
I call it full Loops I've had that
condition depended on
well whatever
um right the okay
so I I wonder if it would be interesting
uh to like you know in the tree view you
know like you have at the bottom there
uh to be able to have some way to uh you
know to pick a node and be able to do
something with it uh interactively you
know get its uh location yeah get its
location maybe copy the entire
expression as a whole
uh
or okay so that's a good idea the other
thing you know I think it's very
important to abstract the information so
like not showing the attributes
um sure that's a legend of the tree but
but the thing John is mentioning which
no I I is great you know in SMP
I hate to say it
in a pretty printed expression one could
right click something well I wasn't
right click in those days it was some
kind of
term cap something or other thing but in
modern times one could right click and
get the part number
which is something we've never been able
to do we should be able to do that
and presumably with Branson's new parser
technology we would be able to do that
not a true statement
uh I mean yeah but I mean getting the
part number isn't hard though
well John how would we could yeah well
so I mean it might be more than the part
number that you want so you might also
want to you know uh snapshot the uh you
know the node or the entire the entire
subtree I know that like copy paste it
special thing if I want to know
that particular you know that particular
element there I would love to have
something here that says part number
copy part number
well something like that one in
particular is a very hard one because
the key of an association okay so
there's no input to part that can get it
but yeah by the way just in reference I
mean the data set does support this
um yes in the limited case of listening
associations yes I know right and and
yeah I mean it's I I agree I think you
want something where you know from
arbitrary Expressions is is a bit
worrisome because of exactly the sort of
thing that Christopher's raising but but
from something that you know
I mean that's still the first part of
that Association though syntactically
you know if you uh you know you have you
know a space b plus C and you point to B
did you want the part of B the part of a
times b or the part of a times B plus C
uh I don't know I'm I'm saying well I as
I remember the way this works in SMP I
hate to bring that back it just went to
the top level of the Rebel it just said
what is the part number relative to the
top level output line well I think the
problem is what do you I think it would
refer to the the smallest atom
yes the thing you selected
well the thing you selected is different
from the smallest atom but yeah
Oh you mean if you have a selection that
spans multiple atoms
well I think the question was okay right
so to make their two cases there's a
case you right click basically on like a
cursor position
like you know you're you're you've just
selected a in the expression a plus b
times C versus you've selected a plus b
in the expression a plus b times C but
in that latter case of course you're in
trouble because a plus b is not yeah
it's not it's not a substrate yeah
right I'm just saying so in that case it
just says sorry I can't do it or it
gives you a forest result with multiple
subtree pieces
anyway can we add that to a user
assistance discussion please yeah yeah
and but you know I I mean my general
point is that I I think you know the
notion of you know going straight down
to an atom is not you know it's not uh I
don't know what people are looking for
your point is in the actual visual
representation of a tree yes
that just like I mean I think that makes
very good sense that there's a right
click here yeah and and this is highly
structured I mean you know you're never
going to get oh accidentally you'll get
the you know the the you know uh you
know uh the the part number of the
second element of source range or
something like that because you clicked
in a silly place you know it's always
the node that you want no I think you're
absolutely right about this I think that
look I think things that you need here
are get me the part number I think you
need to be able to multi-click on this
thing and close up that subtree so that
it is a an alighted subtree
can you do tree outline of that tree
yeah you see I think tree houses needs
quite a bit of of work but the goal is
to bring this closer to like how data
set has all this additional
functionality
you know I think this is good I think it
needs a bit more Framing and a bit more
you know Chrome on it
um by the way you didn't include in your
list of tree-like things the directory
structure stuff from file system tree
I I don't think that's controversial
like that everything's just strings
they're not like structured payloads I
think we should look at it in connection
with these things I think they're going
to be I think that I I don't agree with
you this directories versus files
all kinds of maybe it's obvious but it's
not so obvious to me and certainly in
terms of this XPath stuff I can imagine
wanting to match
I don't even know well I guess in in
like Unix or something you can say slash
star slash and then a file name
and so on right
it's a match in other words you can
match a part yep
and because it has a canonical delimiter
for the path
and in in this case here the analog of
that would be you're going down the tree
and you're matching
uh well insofar as
the directory names correspond to the
keys of associations that Branch at
different nodes and so on
um
okay in any case
um
all right I agree you know what else did
you say John in addition to get me the
part get me the path to that uh
yeah yeah just copy the subtree as an
expression yeah that's a good idea
so it's a it's a tree expression which
which because of the good design of tree
itself this is just a sub-expression
yeah right and and there might be some
way that you could copy the no or that
maybe there's some I don't know enough
about the you know the tree design to
say but there might be something where
you it can get information about the
node without the entire tree maybe used
for pattern matching for example
by just removing it subtrees yeah yeah
so and and that seems potentially useful
if you're trying to build pattern
matching code
I agree I agree those are very good
ideas
um Ian I I think it sounds like you need
to work with somebody in the front-end
team to actually work on how this will
actually work in the you know in the
formatted trees yeah the the kind of
stuff I'm talking about it's work but
it's not insane to implement do we want
to have an attached cell type mechanism
for trees entirely possible I mean that
would be a way that you could click on
click or hover either way on something
and and have it Sprout and interface
that shows you kind of the metadata
behind it and gives you some options of
what to do with it uh is something along
those lines I think is is certainly
possible and potentially interesting
right with respect to this we probably
should have a discussion about how to
Chrome it up
unless you think you already know a path
for that Ian we we need to follow up on
on on that like we had a meeting
a while ago now uh Noah was working on a
new ux okay design for tree outline
okay so weren't we also working on some
front-end thingy
yeah we talked about what was it called
treeview yes
which would I think
help and you know making these things a
reality but yeah so it is is Noah still
working with you guys
uh I I believe that's been inactive
you can check back in okay I mean but if
if you if you're working with them again
I can you know I can talk to him about
some of the concepts that we're
mentioning here just so he understands
uh uh what sort of things to inject
all right this sounds good any lost
comments here so as a practical question
for 13-2 can you scroll back up to the
well
we have
XML and text element and notebook
they're
representing things like just with a
list do we want to
keep these things undocumented in 13 2
until we have
these new I kind of think so we're not
ready yet okay
I mean we could
maybe document them as experimental but
I think even that I think they're a
little bit too everything's experimental
for trees yeah I think what do other
people think I think it's a little too
flaky I think people are going to start
writing with this and they're going to
be upset because it all changes and so
on well technically code freeze is like
in an hour so
right so not gonna happen I mean it this
stuff was implemented in 13-1 it's just
not been documented
right well so we have to get this design
right it's going to take some time to do
that
so I would recommend keeping it
undocumented for now
um
okay anything further here
happy code freezing see you guys later
see ya